la volée pour de vrai jardin exact n'a
pas déjà les gars on a un code rouge
[Musique]
c'est ouf comme vous le savez dans true
story nous recevons des célébrités tels
google dont jeanne isabelle qui viennent
raconter une histoire dengue qui leur
est arrivé tout était fou entre le
raconter une histoire complètement folle
et surtout totalement vrai c'est promis
juré
schuster
[Musique]
on écoute c'était quand il nous faut
tout a commencé j'étais en sûrement lieu
de moscou comprennent le passeport chant
stress 2000 bon alors par besoin jeu
pour un groupe de pression c'est pas un
endroit où on a un tube d'année et c'est
là que j'ai apprise l'hospitalité mongol
super et qu'est ce qui se passe ensuite
je prends un taxi et il ya un couple
d'aubergistes qui assassinent des
voyageurs bonsoir
c'est un film d'horreur en fait
satisfait
[Musique]
je jure de dire la vérité non mais là
c'est chaud
je sens quelque chose se passe je vais
te faire une offre que tu ne peux pas
refuser c'est assez longtemps madone
leur cover couet bonjour
[Musique]
ça déclenche ou
un vrai coup de foudre
j'y vais
et là la vraie fête commence
les noisettes il me faisait pas peur
on faisait peur